well my friends they did it this
shouldn't even be notable this shouldn't
be newsworthy this shouldn't be a story
but 35 republicans
joined democrats in the house of
representatives
to vote to pass a bill that would
set up this bipartisan 911 style
commission to investigate the donald
trump
january 6th insurrection riot
and it is incredible that it is
only 35 members from the republican
party
that joined 176 republicans
uh or one no 175 170 175
175 republicans the vote was 252-175
saying uh we don't want to know what
happened and we don't want
all of these remaining questions
answered in terms of the motivations and
the genesis and the explanation of
why did it take so long to get a
bolstered police presence and the
military all of these different things
that should be investigated
they don't want to know or they
believe that it would point back to them
in some way this is the greatest
motivation for these republicans
not wanting this investigation which is
that many
of them know that it would not look good
for them but we will get back to that
axios is reporting
as i told you yesterday house minority
leader kevin mccarthy
opposed this commission and it looked
like there would be between
20 and 50 republicans who would vote in
favor of it
and 35 did this makes it more
difficult for senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell
to just dismiss it all as partisan
because you did have 35 republicans in
the house who were in favor of it now as
i told you yesterday
the setup is really as bipartisan as you
can get
democrats control the house yes so there
was going to be
some more control that democrats have
rather than republicans over the
commission
but it would be a 10-member commission
five members selected by democrats
five members selected by republicans the
chair
would be a democrat because democrats
control the house and the vice chair
would be a republican
and if they are going to issue subpoenas
uh which presumably they would
every subpoena has to be signed off on
by the chair and the vice chair so there
are republicans i mean listen if i'm
kevin mccarthy
and i realize that i was on the phone
with trump on the day of the
insurrection
and the content of that conversation
may be of interest to the committee and
i might be subpoenaed
um that is going to be something that
would require both
the democratic chair and the republican
vice chair
and indeed there seems to be at least
somewhat of an appetite from republicans
to figure out what happened and so if
you're kevin mccarthy
and you're thinking i might have to
testify here
or at least documents related to my
conversation with trump might be part of
this
it makes sense you would try to make
this go away so the next step here now
that the house has passed it
uh the senate majority leader chuck
schumer democrat from new york
has said the bill will get a vote it's
not clear whether any
republicans in the senate are going to
get on board
two days ago mitch mcconnell said he
can't support it
in its then current form two sources
say that it's conceivable
that mitch mcconnell will have to change
his tune because of these 35 republicans
who voted in favor of it
uh 10 republican senators would be
necessary for this to pass
you cannot pass this in the senate with
50 plus kamala harris as the
tie-breaking vote
that would be the budget reconciliation
process it cannot be used here so in
order for this commission to happen for
it to be voted through in the senate
you will need all 50 democrats and 10
republicans or
49 democrats and 11 republicans or you
can do the math any combination that
gets you to 60.
this could have started months ago there
was no interest before
joe biden was president there was not
even the possibility before joe biden
was president because democrats didn't
didn't control the senate
um and now hopefully we are getting
closer to that it could have been done a
long time ago it really could and it's
because of republicans and republicans
only
that it has not yet happened so we're
going to follow it
and there are any number of different
reasons why different republicans would
want
this not to take place but
i would say i am more confident than
i've been in the last
two weeks today that ultimately this is
going to happen
and let's now look at some of the uh
i don't even really want to call them
reasons because they barely even have
anything to do
with the actual commission and the riots
but let's look at some of the words
that came out of the mouths of
republicans during yesterday's debate
about this on the floor
of the house one of our sponsors is
privacy.com they're giving you
five dollars when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin
air it'll even autofill the card number
with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy
the virtual card number right after
using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
privacy.com pacman